hi guys i'm back again with fran bone
for you last episode we found mr.
midnight and now we're going to make a
potion and help some creepy Siamese
twins so that they will allow us to keep
midnight safe mr. but neither is so
let's carry on so they have given us the
recipe for this spell that we're going
to be makin some of the old lost body
lost in the darkness lost in tears your
body becomes a lie through the hand of
the one angel that decides to be you
sorrow thumbs that's lovely i'm so glad
that was summoning this this lovely
person you will need the hearts of a
frog the head of a young virgin that's
kind of disturbing ok maybe that's when
it was a dead body in the other room
hair and blood from a black pad is that
why they've got mr. midnight all locked
up that's not good a pentagram made of
ashes and the burnt body of a fox I
don't wanna do any of these things this
must be cooked all together inside a pot
or a cauldron with plenty of water ok so
we've already sorted that out last
episode when you are about to drink the
potion repeat these words mumble Pat's
knee or not I can't do that ok so what
are we supposed to do here oh look is
that blue flower kind of like the one
that we grew what does it attract
versions maybe I don't know but yeah but
what are we supposed to do now oh hello
I've seen you before it's him again but
I haven't taken my pills yeah good
observation while he opened the window
that mean that you couldn't escape do I
not have to make this
this creepy potion ah ah cool toad hey
you I need your heart please yes who's
speaking me I am a told I have to tell
you something okay yeah what is it
you're in great danger don't trust the
girls ah why do you say that look girl
I'm a toad and I know I can swim away
from this place but they won't let me
every time I try to get out of here I
magically come back this house is like a
huge magnet a toad and cat magnet they
love us but not to give us love just to
use us don't trust them well that's
terrible that's what my kiddies here
then they gave you a recipe for some
kind of magic right how do you know that
did you see the dead girl in one of the
rooms yes I did well that can be you if
you try to do it she tried but she did
it wrong no no uh what should i do then
I'm not a clever told but if I were you
I would be creative ah creative i'll try
and do my best and gal please save us
all I really want to get out of here how
am I supposed to be great about this I
need your heart I don't know what to do
a big rock I'll leave it there okay so
noon I again a rusty old bicycle in the
middle of an island I don't think it
would take me very far yeah very true
okay should I know okay we're not gonna
kill tude all right then I'm okay with
that take some pills
Delta's need the truth on paper can I
talk to you my sister is trying to catch
me but I ran away what what I'm scared
would you help me I have a monster
inside my head okay then doubters I
guess some people believe you when it's
written down but what does it mean and
who wrote this I'm guessing his hair
right she liked the spirit of one of the
sisters or all the girl who died i'm
guessing the girl who died actually i
have papers yes but what truth oh ok
fight who ok so you can use this plank
as a bridge
attique okay okay i'm reading with this
bottle mm let's cut cut should we cut it
yeah
okay Oh stupid told oh yeah this gives
us like two and one right why I can't
touch the bottle it really burns oh okay
that's weird you whisper witched hmm i
don't know why but i'm going to try this
nope ah oh he do this tweezers to pick
up stuff that my tiny hands can yeah I
know here we go I not the paper what
what this I feel like fighting what
about I need like a frog's heart don't I
okay fine whatever whatever
now okay
now we can go put the paper in the
typewriter but I still don't really know
what we're typing maybe the ghost will
try for us
hmm
oh okay maybe something Oh something on
here but I really the true soul the
world hides the truth from you work your
soul through life and you will
understand the purpose of this act if
you try to corrupt this essence your
soul will be hidden and never see the
face of truth to destroy an impure soul
or give freedom to those who are trapped
you will need okay so this is a real
ritual thing that we need to do not the
other disgusting wrong that uses frog
heart's blood from the executor of the
ritual five okay so about the candles
ashes to form a pentagram serene ashes
maybe we can just burn something like
wood a blue bloomed wouldn't moon
libraries already got that salt and
pepper we got some salt I think we just
need pepper or the other around hair
from the person you want to be which
that's going to be hard draw a pentagram
with the ashes inside the black and
white square put a lighted black candle
on every point of the pentagram
philicorda with water and put the other
elements in it boil pour over the person
you want to be rich and repeat these
words where you walk around them cool
okay then so i need to find stuff stiff
really fun again okay I got pepper and
salt hair ashes blood okay hmm
Oh what's this I've asked to put some
flowers in it it has ashes inside okay
they've got ashes
is there a soap here it's at salt so yes
so okay sweet think of when he now is
the blood there's a this blood in that
bowl though I'll see no that's not the
right one okay so use a salt and pepper
the candles
oh oh my again you don't put them into
the cold room uh the ashes oh okay don't
use the ashes in the culture the rose
yeah I know good fire bloomers um work
what else blood and hair how were you
get there
Oh what this baking soda why do I need
baking soda okay Malik it's the thing
out from the woods it could be him only
bigger he's famous I'll wait the blood
it's supposed to be from the executioner
which they execute an executioner but
that is a friend isn't it so do we like
use it on ourselves oh oh she's so brave
both lesser I'll just let her but now I
have my blood okay so now we have a
bloody knife and some blood awesome ah I
me but we still need the hair which I
think that's gonna be the hardest bit to
find but that's what this in the Gold
Room for now
okay I hope it tastes good are you to
drink it bill okay so if you don't need
this one anymore can we put this into
the typewriter yes yes okay cool so I
like writing some stuff six hair from
your head okay so that's how she's being
creative she's just changing the spell
oh I see no I good at that so now they
think that she can be like oh look I
need your hair okay no we need to find
them where are they where they get so
they were going out then they up there
they are fan here are the materials
you'll need have you studied the ritual
yes but I'll need more time I can't
remember all the words will learn them
fast let us know when you're ready but I
need your hair
girl I think you need help getting rid
of this bag I can do that for you but I
may need it no you don't trust me if we
want to get out of here this bag must
disappear I'll take it you didn't see me
by oh that's one strong frog okay let's
show them the new spell that we've
concocted see how stupid they are to
believe it I'm waiting for your friend
yes yes I know but look look look and as
this one don't show them the real one
look ladies there something missing I
couldn't find your hair in the bag how
you say there is no hair needed we know
that but look for your self it's written
down there in the recipe it doesn't look
forged at all that's true how could we
miss that all right then now we know now
get prepared okay sweet i'll let you
know when i'm ready oh I think I was
wrong but whatever so where do we do the
ritual
this part here I'm guessing why is this
pup in black and white yes so we need to
do it on a black and white flooring and
that is the last part of the potion
let's do it okay now what do some things
with the ashes and stuff
shooks so determined very well done it's
worked out great very messy done from
yeah let's do this for okay put the
candles down I guess we light the
candles sweet and whoa I should show the
girls at the potions ready okay cool
let's count
okay everything's ready let's go to the
kitchen good let's go get me the key
please please
this is stupid please sit down close
your eyes ladies it's not weird at all
they're so trusting I feel slightly bad
only slightly though cuz they're a
pretty mean to me and now I'll say the
words but dear go get a book that what
that matter no way I could say that
either some is knit wait a second that's
not the right spells you tricked us yep
I just did what the Frog till we to do
oh my god services right for being rude
what have I done oh my goodness this is
not right the key now I can free my dear
kitty I'm nervous it's okay they're gone
I'm sure the other ghost is probably
happy because they did kill her
oh we've got to get this down it come
down anyway yes what is it Fran open the
cage I can't McKay doesn't fit Oh what
did you see another key holes and what
yes we did it was on the mirror in that
creepy room I'll be waiting hurry up
okay we've got to get mr. Mudd night out
of here in this episode we're gonna do
this so that's how Alex
the key is for this keyhole and what's
that a puzzle okay what is this I guess
I have to open this thing about how hmm
where where are we trying to travel to
hmm what am i doing I don't know oh ok
move cogs and stuff oh I see I see ok
that one can't move oh yeah finally you
don't know how long that took what oh
wow well that was very unexpected what
what is this two skeletons is it like
what those girls were just murderers I
don't feel bad at all Oh sister promise
we clara and mia / helmets promise to
avenge the unfair destiny it were
decided for us with blood and tears who
promise that we will kill him and bring
our bodies back we won't stand this any
longer even though we're sisters we hate
each other and we will always hate each
other nothing will ever change that but
now with our bodies attached to each
other we can't complete our task the
strongest will live forever and the
weakest will die
mother must die oh that's horrible oh
the sisters have a huge scar in the
middle so someone did that to them on
purpose and they wanted to get their
revenge is that the potion that I was
doing that they wanted me to do for them
I don't it this game is just full of so
much creepier I love it there okay so
we've got we've got the key now I'm
guessing this is the correct key I think
this is the key it worked My dear Kitty
it worked come on let me hug you dad
yeah
oh so much happiness that good ah this
feels so good i'm free Fran my good
friend you are free now let's go home
yes let's go well what are those babies
are look in the pram let's just leave
them there's nothing we can do for them
look look at him how are we gonna get
home they I'm guessing yourself this way
need to get home kitty I hope the way
back isn't far away how do we get home I
hope so too fun we do this together I
can help you he says and then he licks
his bum gave you a key I did it so toad
the girls are gone that is perfect now I
can leave this place and go to my family
I want to do that too said I finally
found my kitty I just want to go home
now and be with armed grace but how will
you get out of there there is no boat um
I thought you could help us get out I
would love to help you but I'm too tiny
even though my body is quite moldable it
would be quite impossible to carry over
to the other side let me think about it
don't leave us yet please okay I've got
to find a way out got baking powder but
I don't know how that's gonna help us
okay so we've got baking powder which
makes things bigger and the toad said
that he was too small
take this tote in might help I'm not a
bakery fun but you are all slimy and
soft like dough he doesn't taste like
bread there you're right in my work here
it goes what up it's got like 20 years
like a cat it worked I'm so big and I
feel gorgeous yeah you look fabulous
great let's go come mr. the night sure
Fran I only have one complaint that
giant toad is staring at me what are you
talking about it just wants to help us
all right but if you try anything I will
scratch him that's okay but try not to
hurt him so much while we're sitting on
him the water is deep and we don't know
what kind of creatures are in there if
we fall in the water we could die or I
promise I won't scratch to get the toad
before we go and forgot to give you
something I saw you in the picture so I
thought it was yours ah I thought we
lost that in the sewers and this book
was with it too oh what's that book I
told you found my family photos thank
you so much I thought I'd lost it
forever but the book isn't mine Oh we'll
take the books a gift it's always
healthy to read and it has many pictures
thank you I like pictures let's go now
yes here we go so cool I want a road on
a giant toad that was so much fun ah
it's like an old school games
okay right threat Chef Season thing yeah
I think that way okay it's one of those
like jumping on the planks okay cool
yeah right this one this one they like
made out of plasticine oh this is
awesome go to yes oh it's more oh I
thought
oh no quickly it was that like yes oh no
I need to get here I love this I love
the outside this is so awesome this game
is just so creative i love it oh [ __ ]
quickly oh my god I'm sake I don't even
know anything was coming
yes okay we're into a new place here we
all jump off now let's go
now it's time to go home I hope you find
your family's inserted thank you you too
farewell goodbye sir thank you for the
ride van what should we do now find a
way back home do you see the sky is done
and really soon all the scary things
will disappear I'm so hungry and sleepy
I want to go home now mean teen will
find the way I do my best to help you
let's go okay ah so happy then we've got
our cat back now let's read this journal
I'm very intrigued oh I was a scary
masks that we saw I found myself hunting
the truth but finding the unexpected I
found what my senses couldn't show me I
found the truth that relays silently in
the unknown Leon custody of one of the
thousand my name is Leon i'm currently
92 years old and living alone in the
little house far away from the city I
have to admit I never was fond of
jewelry houses or clothing since
childhood I always talk to animals
plants and insects sounds like me and so
I've never forgot never got a response I
never quit if you are reading this maybe
it's because you were looking for
answers maybe you can see things that
others can't or you feel what others
avoid you can listen to the silence and
become one with everything December 17th
1875 I can't stop it I can't control it
I see the black shadows everywhere the
blood the messages are screaming all the
pain I can't figure out why this is
happening to me cry visit because it
hurts inside my head the stone of wisdom
inside my head
I had a vision I'm still breathing fear
I feel more with my own mind one of the
shadows came down from the sky I thought
it was an angel its name is the more
Prince of Darkness for the fifth wheels
from the fifth real reality oh I see it
talked to me played with me and showed
me all the terrors it told me that I was
the key to its existence I can see
myself around the other the other tell
me tell me lies talks about all the pain
and suffering in my life the other me
once made you commit suicide these
smiles while pronouncing the words kill
yourself and I have tried hypnotized by
his words but there is always something
saving me at the end it must be the love
to live I meet a shadow for the first
time it talked to me the race is called
the cameras they hunt weakness and pain
I asked it about the possession of human
bodies and it said we are all born and
feed from fear and the uncontrolled
illness of human mind if we are no we
are invisible to them but our existent
grabs every single living cell of the
body until the end after that it started
raining and it walked away from me
leaving a black oily path after it I
believe water may purify them after
seeing the commander's reacting to water
I thought of trying a little experiment
last night I encountered something
amazing the commander's transform into a
new kind of creature when exposed to
water the metamorphosis was painful to
watch after the terrible screaming the
Kamala's come down and started to cry on
the ground it felt like the pain was
disappearing after a few minutes a
bright and peaceful being was rising in
front
me it felt like the bright creature
could read my thoughts I thank you for
waking me up I was suffering I thirst
der awaits oh I must go where I belong I
Sarah awaits all the locos must go there
after waking up if you wish to seen the
light come with me you have the key it
said I didn't answer after a while it
faded away I was really am I writing to
see if I'm missing something I recall
remote from the fifth reality if there
is a fist reality there must be at least
four more I was thinking that a thirst
or may not be a city in this world but a
reality by itself I wish all answers
came to me I deeply regret the fact that
I did not accept the volokh as
invitation since i saw the volokh as i
keep seeing this diagram spinning in my
head and a single sentence time is the
rhythm of your perception I got a visit
from my son Brian I told him about the
things that I've seen but he didn't want
to hear and left I don't blame him i
understand that reality presented before
my eyes as invisible to most people i
wish i could find a friend just like me
because my son he thinks i'm insane my
body and mind are beginning to
understand the pattern life becomes
quite easy to control when you cut all
social wars and only apply our reality
laws because they are not only laws but
also behaviors chemical behaviors
natural laws without those behaviors
without those laws we wouldn't exist
sometimes I wish to be a leaf on the
ground Tom while dying last night after
the storm a huge creature visited my
garden for a few seconds and then
disappeared I found a strange bottle
with a pink liquid inside in the same
spots the creature had landed I can't
fully understand the condo
to the bottle i have found red blood
cells in it and bacteria not for it yet
recognized the bacteria seems to get rid
of the unusual behaviors in any kind of
living creature i poured some of the
pink liquid on a dying plants and it
bloomed after a few minutes I cut my
finger to test the liquid with human
tissue and it cured it after a few
seconds this bacteria may work us as
plug palau tell its flat ellipse and
white blood cells but at a very high
speed I dream of a thousands of black
cats surrounding my house big yellow
eyes staring at my sleep beings in a
thirst are varied from roots to giant
insects roots at the very at the first
and this reality insects came later I
learned their language and numerology
this is so crazy what I'm my mind is
like boggling right now I'm so confused
The Grateful occurs is the beginning of
the first vr z prime eve light the bell
lopez body structure is quite different
from ours they are made out of patent
photons and soundwaves they're also both
male and female when the youngster reach
age very big age they are crowned with
the shield zia creation of the Grateful
locust king of Arthur stirs second
reality life being in a festive feels
like becoming what you can't understand
on earth it's where leaves sing while
falling off the tree and the water
whispers its wisdom while you drink it
Pandora creation of five well rounds of
essential existence
resides in the human world third reality
as Mars and Jupiter consciousness
practice of will cenar Siddi the end of
vibration when both ends of opposites
are the same degree resides in 3rd and
4th reality death mabuk ER is the end of
light mother mapouka is letting me go I
spent 15 days here in my bukas den and
I'm tired I don't need to hide from pain
anymore because it's part of me it feels
like love is everywhere and in
everything I enjoy crying I enjoy
laughing I enjoy being alive that's
that's good I how many pages that I'll
get no tape recorded I'm getting ready
for the journey back home my book has
sent me to endless limits of malukas den
and i'm waiting for the loose friends i
had to become friends with them or to be
more precise to become one of them Lusa
friends gather in filaments that's why
they look like they're growing hair and
the big face is mostly for communication
wait so those are things that we freed
from the tree when we combed the hair
they turn to little like moths it was
used for communication purposes and to
scare their predators I hope my body can
survive the journey gravity collects
particles to create new ones it's a
creative force and with creativity
evolution is inevitable
my brain is like frazzled right now that
was so much information so there's five
realities and so I was right the pill is
kind of like another reality I think but
there's five so I'm guessing we're gonna
like explore so many different
dimensions here and not all of them hold
evil things some things are nice and
this is crazy what's your theories let
me know in the comments below and as
always let me know if you enjoyed this
and give this a thumbs up if you did and
have loved Aires mean by oh hello oh my
gosh what happened in this room hello I
love our friends always just like hey
you're like half dead or your your
creepy baby but I'm just gonna say hey
to you who are you